arrêtons nous un instant sur une
nouvelle manière de fraude est inventée
par un candidat au baccalauréat
d'orléans pas question pour lui
d'employer les vieux trucs du genre
antisèches dissimulé sur les poignées de
chemise ou encore formule inscrite dans
le creux de la main non ce jeune homme
et sa petite amie avait décidé
d'utiliser le dernier gadget à la mode
c'est à dire la civi
c'est marcel trillât qui a reconstitué
pour vous cette combine pas comme les
autres regardez alors roumanie deux cent
trente sept mille cinq cents kilomètres
carrés population totale 22 millions
d'habitants population active 10
millions 35
qu'est ce que tu veux aller production
alors céréales 20 millions de tonnes
dont 6 20 millions de tonnes et 6 de
pelé et 15 de maïs un set au temps passe
si vite possible
ok vas-y
est-ce que tu ton compris bien sûr j'ai
légèrement passé l'âge et dominique
tiers c'est beaucoup trop honnête pour
se prêter à une telle supercherie mais
enfin c'est à peu près ce qui s'est
passé avant-hier aux épreuves du bac bep
au lycée jean zay d'orléans le petit
malin était ainsi beast fervent il
disposait d'un émetteur récepteur à peu
près gros comme ceux ci de deux petits
écouteurs dissimulé dans une chevelure
évidemment beaucoup plus abondante que
la mienne et d'un micro gros comme un
noyau de cerise caché par un foulard
dans une voiture garée dans une rue des
environs sa petite amie complaisante
disposer de tous les ouvrages
nécessaires pour faire face à n'importe
quelle épreuve d'histoire géo du bac b
la triche était presque parfaite
presque seulement en effet il y avait
une faille n'importe quel 6 bis de
passage dans les environs pouvait
entendre plus aussi le dialogue et c'est
ce qui s'est produit
donc de chance de cibistes indiscrets et
est aussi un citoyen très à cheval sur
les principes il s'est donc aussitôt
précipité au rectorat où il a tout
raconté
quelques minutes plus tard le petit
richer été démasqués à cause aussi de
sens nous sa chevelure tout de même
votre pas bon dans tes de ce foulard
plutôt insolite par ces chaleurs
il lui en coûtera 5 ans d'interdiction
de bach
mais est ce vraiment une punition ça lui
permettra en tout cas de réviser
soigneusement pour pouvoir affronter la
prochaine fois des épreuves du bac mais
sans accessoire
[Musique]